on a des cours des choses absolument
hallucinantes dans les méthodes de ces
énormes sociétés et ils ont fait cinq
caméras cachées on va découvrir tout de
suite les méthodes d'Amazon regardez
c'est édifiant pendant 7 heures avec une
seule pose de 30 minutes je dois vider
42 colis par heure de 5 kg en moyenne
soit plus d'une tonne 4 d'articles
apportés par jour à la fin de la journée
le manager nous regroupe pour nous
annoncer notre productivité sur la
dernière heure 36 c'est bien ou pas
[Musique]
le message est clair mais performant son
comparés à celle des autres et je dois
faire mieux sur les cinq intérimaires
embauchés en même temps que notre
journaliste au bout de 10 jours de son
parti où ont été remerciés une a fait un
malaise quant à notre journée il a perdu
trois kilos
ah oui c'est comme des méthodes très
particulières c'est des extrêmement
intenses oui Isabelle d'ailleurs tout
n'était pas en caméra cachée
qui disait comment il avait réussi à
gagner 2 secondes de productivité sur
les chaînes d'emballage de Sarenza et
alors vraiment ils le disait ça avec une
immense fierté est-ce que ça pourrait
changer vos façons de consommer de votre
reportage ça dépend
pas du tout
on parle en France mais il faut pas
oublier que en Asie c'est des millions
de chinois par exemple
ça c'est différent
rajouter des employés pour désengorger
un petit peu les usines françaises et
pour pas forcément que ça atténue les
heures de travail tout simplement ouais
non moi je suis hyper choqué parce qu'on
a vu parce que faut aussi rappeler un
chiffre hyper important c'est qu'à
Amazon ils sont sur le point de
licencier plus de 10000 personnes il y a
une deuxième vague de licenciement qui
va arriver on connaît pas le chiffre
pourquoi pour une raison toute simple
puisqu'ils ont fait des bénéfices
records pendant le covid parce qu'on a
acheté tous comme des fous sur le sur le
net depuis ça a baissé donc ils vont
très bien simplement pour rester dans
leur bénéfices d'origine ils vont
licencier à Torre et à travers pour
rester alors ils ont des méthodes pour
améliorer encore la productivité et vous
allez voir que les les mecs sont
carrément traqués quoi
donc en fait c'est un gant avec un
lecteur de code à barre celui-ci pèse 45
g et il est déclenché avec le pouce on
gagne environ une ou deux secondes sur
le scan d'un article
grâce à ce système les salariés traitent
20 articles de plus par heure depuis son
bureau Franck a installé une vraie tour
de contrôle sur son ordinateur il suit
en temps réel les performances
individuelles de ces salariés pour ceux
qui dépassent l'objectif il a instauré
une prime de 50 euros qui s'ajoute au
salaire mensuel de base de 1750 euros
brut mais gare à ceux qui n'atteignent
pas les quotas de production ils sont
aussitôt repérés dans le poste 5
effectivement en fait il est en dessous
des autres donc là il va falloir les
voir ce qui se passe sur le poste ah
c'est terrible finalement c'est surtout
que c'est malheureux parce que c'est les
personnes à la base qui sont des humains
qui sont transformés limites en match
là-bas ce sont des hommes mais c'est
vrai que les personnes qui sont autour
d'elle les considèrent et aussi des
femmes les considèrent comme des
machines et égal toujours en
productivité et le pire en plus c'est
que ce sont des métiers ne sont pas
beaucoup payés malgré les choses qui
leur arrivent par exemple au bras
tendinite etc
alors moi je me suis un petit peu
renseigné j'ai appelé un contact chez
Amazon au niveau de la communication
c'est vrai que le reportage il aura pas
été vendu de cette manière là donc la
Réda chef du reportage en question a
pris contact avec David le coïts le
président d'Amazon Amazon France
logistique ils ont pu justement visiter
l'entrepôt pendant à peu près 6 heures
elle a rencontré une dizaine de salariés
qui étaient aussi très content de la
manière dont ils étaient très séchés
Amazon et ils mettent un peu en valeur
le fait que dans le reportage bah ça n'a
pas existé qu'ils ont monté que les
aspects négatifs donc ils vont pas faire
un portage pour les filles vont bien
Amazon
je pense qu'ils ont donné beaucoup de
travail dans des dans des endroits où
dans des zones géographiques où il y
avait besoin de boulot donc ouais et pas
que du mal du mauvais chez Amazon juste
vous connaissez donc Chine
Shin soit vous avez beaucoup travaillé
avec eux
ils ont une méthode pour vendre leurs
produits qui sont alors c'est en fait
c'est comme ça ça ressemble à quelque
chose ça a la couleur de quelque chose
mais c'est pas
les clients de ce film lors de leur
grand déballage avec des collines qui
déborde de vêtements voici à quoi
ressemble les coulisses de ces vidéos
avec son père Alexandre qui s'occupe de
la technique c'était la 18 ans réalise
deux vidéos par mois pour la marque
chinoise
la longue avec l'habitude
tu es là a compris
pour capter l'attention chaque essayage
ne doit pas durer plus de 5 secondes à
l'écran entre le tournage et le montage
une vidéo pour Chine ces deux heures de
travail elle n'est pas payée pour cela
en revanche les vêtements sont offerts
des fois qui sont rémunérés en échange
de produits alors c'est du sponsoring
quand même c'est considéré comme du
sponsoring quand même mais effectivement
ils sont pas payés il y en a certains
qui sont payés
franchement ça m'aurait
c'est pas un secret il y a pas de il y a
pas de souci maintenant après Chine
c'est vrai qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
polémiques
ils copient tous les modèles sans sans
payer les droits et cetera c'est vrai
que c'est un gros bordel c'est des
petits prix ça permet aussi à des
familles de m'avoir s'habiller on est
ils ont pas la prétention de dire qu'ils
sont ce qu'ils n'ont pas maintenant
effectivement c'est petit prix moi par
contre la qualité je trouve que pour le
prix elle est elle est plutôt bien ce
qui a fait buzz enfin bad buzz ça a été
les conditions de travail des employés
et nous il y a 15 jours on a reçu un
courrier je voulais amené à un
communiqué de la marque Shein pour nous
expliquer que effectivement dû aux
médias grâce aux médias ils se sont
aperçus que certains fournisseurs parce
qu'il sous traitent des fois ont eu des
enfin ils ont maltraité certains
employés et donc ils ont des enquête
voilà la maltraitance merci ils ont mené
une enquête ils ont mis les moyens merci
c'est gentil on se complète bien vous et
moi mais voilà ils ont mis des ils ont
mis les moyens ils ont ils ont débloqué
des budgets et ils mesure du meilleur
suivi pour pour
1000 entreprises qui fabriquent pour
Chine donc va trouver les problématiques
à l'intérieur après ça fait peut-être
travailler
derrière effectivement il y a des
problèmes de conditions et de il paye
quasiment peu ou pas d'impôts en France
donc finalement c'est assez situation
mamie est très choquée non mais moi il y
a un truc qui me désespère aucun de vous
n'a pensé ne l'a dit c'est que tous les
terres agricoles 550 000 hectares de
terre agricoles pas alors qu'on en aura
besoin dans 20 ans pour nourrir 8
milliards
disparaissent au profit d'immense
entrepôts comme ça qui saccage
absolument tout et qui c'est des termes
en plus
personne dans des régions des affectées
agricoles et qu'on aura les entrepôts
qui aura toujours les gens à nourrir on
sera bien bien
en fait on peut pas mettre ça sur le dos
des consommateurs qui de toute façon
n'ont pas les moyens de consommer
éco-responsables il y a des alternatives
c'est pas vrai ça non non il y a des
gens qui ont pas le choix de toute façon
dont vous êtes habillé là il commence
par un Z qui commence par un H elles
sont toutes données dans les mêmes pays
oui Zed voilà
démagogie parce que là on joue les
consommateurs il y avait deux
collections par an maintenant on a créé
des collections dans ce genre de magasin
et je suis la première à consommer tous
les 15 jours d'un truc qui change
après
vous consommez de tous les 15 jours de
non j'achète plein de merde
c'est pas aux gens de c'est pas aux gens
de trouver des solutions c'est au
gouvernants ce qui nous dirige de
trouver des solutions c'est pas au
contraire vous savez qu'il y a des
marques maintenant il y a des grandes
enseignes qui exigent si il est
responsable aussi et ben quand tu vas
chez H et bah c'est pareil
aujourd'hui maintenant les grandes
marques renouvelle les vitrines parfois
deux fois par jour pour que les gens
s'il repasse ils achètent autre chose
un petit peu ce que godisait alors
évidemment qu'on doit se sentir nous
aussi responsable parce que
malheureusement on en demande et plus on
nous en donne et plus on en veut donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a aussi une façon de
se responsabiliser maintenant qu'on le
veuille ou non à l'ancienne il y avait
déjà eu des grandes polémiques avec la
fameuse vous savez il y a toutes les
grandes marques produisent des
délocaliser avec des productions qui ont
fait appel voire des enfants donc c'est
un vrai scandale moi ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que j'ai envie de parler
vraiment c'est que on fait tous les
choquer à chaque fois qu'on voit un
reportage comme ça et on achèterai on
sait que ça existe depuis longtemps que
ça existe depuis des années et il y a
que à partir de il y a pas longtemps là
je vois que tout le monde vient ah oui
c'est pas normal ça me choque hé on fait
c'est depuis la nuit des temps
après il faut penser à ces gens-là aussi
qui travaillent il faut leur donner du
respect parce que les gens qui
travaillent dans l'ombre généralement on
leur donne pas assez de mise en lumière
donc moi je trouve justement que ce
reportage c'est bien aussi justement
qu'on puisse en débattre et qu'on puisse
montrer les gens dans l'ombre qui
travaille parce que il y a ceux qui
travaillent en France ceux qui sont qui
aujourd'hui à l'étranger qui sont
extrêmement
quand on travaille à la chaîne comme ça
c'est quand même un travail quoi qu'il
arrive qu'on soit en France en étranger
c'est c'est le même travail
oui ou non vous êtes prêts à boycotter
ce genre de marque possible
les régions les élus qui accorde des
trucs comme ça les gens qui achètent au
début
de construire des je suis prêt à
maîtriser ma consommation quand je vois
les conditions de travail abominable des
dégâts je crois qu'il y a des
alternatives je te jure bien joué
avec des sabots en bois
pour nous ouvrir les yeux sur cette
formation
en fait c'est très beau mais c'est
totalement démagogique
on peut faire des erreurs on est là
aussi pour
enlever vos chaussures donnez-nous
[Applaudissements]
on va faire un petit lien pour les
cadeaux
en France par les entreprises françaises
justement c'est juste que aujourd'hui
mais effectivement il y a beaucoup
d'influenceurs qui font la promo de ces
marques là notamment comme chez in juste
pour obtenir un sac une paire de
chaussettes gratuites je fais appel à
tous ces influenceurs contactez des
petits producteurs contactez des gens
qui ont besoin aussi de visibilité
différemment et
des chiens ça sert à rien
la plupart
la plupart nous appellent ou pas ou
influenceurs quand les grosses marques
les appels ils sont tout le temps même
pour mais bien sûr si personne fait
d'effort donc du coup on reste comme ça
il y a rien qui bouge comme ça et même
si toi tu fais
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pour conclure ça a fonctionné capital ça
a bien fonctionné 3e de la soirée près
de 2 millions
et records sur les cibles merci merci